jean françois schmitt merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors vous
avez participé ce matin aux commissions
sociale et économique de votre
entreprise nokia à lannion vous avez
informé les salariés de leur sort cette
vague de licenciements vous vous y
préparer ou cela a été une annonce
brutale
ben c'était ça a été une annonce
vraiment à total et un peu à contre
courant parce que en fait nous avait
annoncé la semaine avant que les
chiffres étaient bons économiquement la
société se portait bien
on a des signes et autres arts yao koffi
il fait il y avait besoin au lait et les
réseaux donc posée comment en x est un
peu longue file donc tous les voyants
étaient au vert et d'ampleur et là on
est complètement abasourdi sans vraiment
trahi trahi parce que jean françois
schmitt quels sont les secteurs touchés
par ces suppressions de postes et
comment sont elles justifiées par
l'équipementier télécoms finlandais
donc nous dit c'est que aulas a un
problème de compétitivité encore faire
plus de marge au niveau des et produire
le on a donc c'est pour se rencontrer
beaucoup de délocalisations dans des
pays à bas coûts en fait on ne supprime
pas la charge de travail mais allez
simplement on fait délocaliser purement
et simplement dans des pays à bas coûts
comme la pologne ou l'indre et
et donc est donc assez pour faire des
rideaux ou et et ce temps sans stratégie
autre que la reine qui ou quoi alors
face à ces réductions de coûts ont voulu
par l'entreprise comment est ce que vous
allez vous mobiliser pour défendre les
emplois notamment sur le site de lannion
sur le site de lannion on a des vrais
savoir-faire en terme de deux ans de
développement 5g notamment et les accès
réseau sur les accès radio et ces
équipes là aujourd'hui sont menacés il y
avait aussi tout ce qui est au coeur de
réseau avec les bases de données
d'abonnés qui aujourd'hui toute
l'activité ont fait va être délocalisée
alors que c'est quand même un en termes
de sécurité c'est quand même très
important de conserver ces
développements on va dire non dans en
europe de l'ouest donc on comprend pas
la logique même la logique en terme de
sécurité n'est pas respectée quoi et en
plus on avait récupéré des
développements de cybersécurité même ces
développements de cybersécurité sont
sont souvent arrêtés donc on est
complètement basse loaded au devant de
tels agissements
ces eaux alors le ministre le ministre
de l'économie a réagi pour lui nokia
doit être amélioré très
significativement son plan de
suppression
comment selon vous le gouvernement
doit-il convaincre nokia de revoir son
plan il doit déjà rappelé à nokia tous
ses engagements qui ont été pris et qui
ne sont pas complètement tenus il ya
déjà notamment les engagements sur la
cybersécurité lannion devait être un
pôle de cybersécurité aujourd'hui on
arrête des activités cybersécurité c'est
inadmissible
en plus tout ce qui est sécurité des
réseaux notamment dans l'est sur le
développement
de base de données d'abonnés ça c'est
quand même quelque chose de critiques en
termes de sécurité des réseaux et
aujourd'hui on veut le délocaliser ou
l'inde
donc voilà c'est un problème de
souveraineté
quelques par l'état français en terme de
sécurité sous le règne t2 devrait
devrait agir à ce niveau là merci
beaucoup jean françois schmitt d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes délégué syndical cfe cgc nokia